la momie est probablement le symbole le
plus évident de la civilisation de
l'egypte ancienne
au début on enterrait les défunts loin
des sols fertiles ce qui crée
naturellement des momies la chaleur du
soleil et le sable du désert avait pour
effet de conserver la peau est ainsi la
forme humaine du défunt ce processus est
à l'origine des croyances mystérieuse
qui en ont découlé
la momie représentait une lueur d'espoir
en fait l'obscurité de la mort on
espérait que si le corps pouvaient être
préservés alors l'âme de la personne
pouvait continuer à vivre la momie était
le symbole humain du plus grand dieu des
égyptiens
comme le soleil qui se lève et se couche
le défunt pourra vivre de nouveau pour
les égyptiens la momie est l élément
central dont on avait besoin pour
atteindre l'immortalité
après la mort le défunt se séparerait en
de nombreuses parties sans forme qui
seraient réunis à nouveau grâce à
l'aspect soigneusement préservée de la
momie
tout le monde voulait être momifiée pour
assurer le processus de conservation les
égyptiens ont développé un procédé
artificielle produisant les mêmes
résultats que l'environnement la
momification est devenu un véritable
commerce l'egypte ancienne avait ainsi
découvert le secret de la modification
il s'agissait de la déshydratation ils
ont utilisé cette connaissance et ont
ensuite élaboré un procédé qui pouvaient
durer jusqu'à 70 jours
c'était durant cette période que l'on
enlevait beaucoup d'organes tout
particulièrement le cerveau que l'on
retirait petit à petit à l'aide d'un bon
crochet
après avoir enlevé les organes internes
on mettait le corps dans du natron un
genre de substances qui ressemblait du
sel et que l'on pouvait trouver en
egypte trente cinq jours plus tard les
embaumeurs revenait pour finir leur
travail
mais cette fois ils n'étaient pas seuls
des prêtres en costumes étranges
murmuraient des formules pour assurer le
passage du défunt dans l'au-delà à
cordes ou des vins que la respiration
traversé sa tête dans lola est illusoire
ses yeux à la fin du rituel on déposait
le corps dans un autre symbole
persistants de l'egypte ancienne
le tombeau
les égyptiens l'appelait la maison
éternelle la tombe était destiné à
protéger la momie indéfiniment au cours
du développement de l'egypte ancienne la
construction des tombes tout comme la
momification a évolué le tombeau est
devenu un genre de montagne mythologique
à l'origine de toute création
ah ah
les tons sont passés de simples tombeau
de sable à des structures aplati clé
mastaba puis en 2006 ans avant
jésus-christ le mastaba a donné
naissance à une évolution architecturale
en superposant ces structures qui
ressemble à des bancs on éleva la
première pyramide la pyramide à degrés
de saqqara
pendant deux siècles la construction de
la pyramide a continué à évoluer en 2004
sans avant jésus-christ l'egypte
ancienne a atteint le sommet du
développement des pyramides
ce qui a donné une des sept merveilles
du monde les pyramides de gizeh elles
représentaient les tombeaux monumentaux
de trois générations de momies royales
leur structure solide et est conçu pour
permettre au puissant pharaon
d'atteindre l'au delà
dollars il bénit c'est ces sujets qui
étaient loyaux perpétuant ainsi le style
de vie des égyptiens
c'était un voyage obligatoire que l'on
essayé d'assurer à l'extérieur aussi
bien qu'à l'intérieur des pyramides
le plateau où se trouvent ces
gigantesques triangle de granit avait un
gardien
le sphinx fait de calcaire il veillait
comme une sentinelle l'énorme animal à
tête humaine était à l'image de cafra le
roi dont il protégeait le complexe de
pyramides les gens de l'époque pensaient
que le sphinx représentait le roi défunt
et cela faisait plus de mille ans qui
lui apportaient leurs offrandes
pour les égyptiens les statuts y compris
le sphinx était souvent aussi sacrée que
les mobiles on en trouvait beaucoup dans
les tombeaux mais contrairement aux
momies elles étaient visibles elle
servait de représentants et assurer la
sécurité face à toute éventualité
destructive le sphinx les pyramides de
gizeh et les momies sont des trésors
mystérieux de l'antiquité qui sont
devenus synonymes des gens de l'époque
il montre que les gens s'étaient mis en
guerre contre leur propre mortalité
c'était une lutte qui continuerait aussi
longtemps que leur civilisation mais
l'ont finalement perdu après avoir
laissé cependant un compte rendu
détaillé de leurs croyances
o qui possédait les âmes qui essore de
roche qui existe et dernièrement
recevrez des moins car je suis un esprit
de l'armada board et les pouvoirs
rayamajhi soulevé l'émoi de mes
agresseurs dans ce pays juste ce sont
les murmures des aïeuls ce sont les
échos du passé
j'ai recueilli c'était magie dans tous
les endroits où il se trouvait et de
tous ceux et d'averses et ce sont les
formules magiques anciennes ce sont les
paroles nécessaires dont il pensait
avoir besoin pour atteindre
l'immortalité
oh toi le grand dieu seigneur de la
justice
je suis venu à la boisse seigneur je
n'ai pas fait de tort à autrui
je n'ai fait de mal je n'ai pas achevé
je suis tu pues pur pur
ce sont les traductions des inscriptions
égyptienne ce sont des hiéroglyphes
le mot hiéroglyphes vient du grec et
veut dire inscriptions sacré puisqu'ils
étaient surtout des prêtres qui étaient
instruits quand les grecs sont arrivés
ils ont déclaré que les inscriptions
étaient religieux s'ils étaient donc
sacré
les grecs n'étaient pas loin de la
vérité car pour les égyptiens les
hiéroglyphes et est sacré
qu'ils soient peints de nombreuses
couleurs ou simplement inscrit il
transmettait des renseignements
importants
se sont littéralement les paroles
divines nommé d'une terre comme on les
appelait dans l'egypte ancienne
on considérait les hiéroglyphes non
seulement comme un don fait aux dieux
mais aussi comme un moyen puissant de
transcender la vie et la mort
on pouvait donc communiquer ainsi entre
le monde ici bas et l'au-delà avec les
ancêtres des fins et les dieux ce moyen
permettait de passer d'un monde à
l'autre et d'aider à contrôler les
forces appartenant à l'au-delà sur
lesquels on aurait normalement aucun
pouvoir en dépit du fait que l'egypte
ancienne se sentait toute puissante sa
culture a subi l'influencé
d'envahisseurs et la domination d'une
nouvelle forme de culte
le dernier et hiéroglyphes a été
inscrits durant le quatrième siècle
après jésus-christ ici dans le temple de
philae à et à la fin quand tous les
prêtres égyptiens étaient décédés on a
perdu avec eux la capacité de lire ces
inscriptions sacré
pendant presque 1500 ans
ces voix venant du lointain restée
silencieuse pendant des siècles les
experts ont essayer de déchiffrer ces
symboles aux formes étranges mais
restant souvent perplexe ils se
permettaient de compenser leurs lacunes
en matière de connaissances par leur
imagination
au xviie siècle on a suggéré que les
hiéroglyphes contenait les mystères de
l'univers
ensuite au xviiie siècle on a pu voir
avancer les recherches grâce à napoléon
bonaparte qui a envahi l'egypte
en 1798 napoléon est arrivé dans le pays
avec une armée de soldats et des
égyptologues
il a ainsi amené des soldats pour
combattre l'ennemi et des experts pour
mesurer les monuments étudié
l'architecturé copier les inscriptions
les recherches de ces égyptologue était
destiné à mieux comprendre cette
civilisation disparue
cependant la découverte la plus
intéressante a été faite non par un
expert mais par un soldat qui est devenu
responsable de la mise à jour d'un
artefact ouvrant les portes du passé
durant l'été 1799 les français
commençaient à perdre la guerre contre
les britanniques qui avaient aussi
envahi les gîtes de façon à fortifier
leur défense les français avaient décidé
de reconstruire un fort arabe le long du
nil près de la ville de rosette tout en
démolissant les murailles de la
forteresse
un soldat a trouvé une stèle pesant
environ 680 kg il s'agit de la stèle que
l'on appellera plus tard la pierre de
rosette
la pierre de rosette était la première
découverte de ce genre elle contenait
les trois types d'inscription commune à
l'egypte ancienne
il y avait des inscriptions sacré ou
hiéroglyphes une autre forme d'écriture
antique appelé démotique et un texte en
grec que l'on peut encore interprété de
nos jours
cependant malgré la familiarité de
certains passages en grec
la pierre de rosette n'était pas tout à
fait complète est ainsi difficile à
déchiffrer
pendant plus d'une vingtaine d'années
les experts ont essayé de trouver la
signification de ces inscriptions
mystérieuse après des heures de
recherches le fils d'un libraire jean
françois champollion âgé de 32 ans a pu
trouver le code permettant de déchiffrer
la pierre de rosette
elle contenait les remerciements des
prêtres écrit en 196 avant jésus-christ
pour le pharaon nommé tollé mais cinq
champollion avait ainsi démontré que les
hiéroglyphes était plus qu'une écriture
formaient d'image
il symbolisait des sons et des concepts
son travail a marqué la fin du silence
on a pu entendre à nouveau les voix de
l'antiquité à travers la lecture des
hiéroglyphes la voyage dans l'endroit de
telle est issu elle ne peut pas châtier
loi ces écoutes moi maintenant c'est que
déjà 10 et 11 ans 100 m
cela pourra apporter les riediens
l'avant du corps elles changent elles
évoluent l'allergie agit en l
tu n'as qu'un nouveau garder on nous
décrit ces zones au pays
nous sommes chez nous
on n'avait plus à deviner ni à faire des
suppositions on pouvait simplement lire
les inscriptions on pouvait comprendre
qu'ils étaient les pharaons ont pouvait
lire leur nom
on a pu ainsi trouver l'ordre
chronologique des règnes par exemple qui
régnait après ramsès ou avant tout mot
six auparavant on se fie à quelques
indices laissés par les grecs alors
l'égyptologie avancer de façon
remarquable après le déchiffrement des
hiéroglyphes l'égyptologie avait une
nouvelle compréhension de la culture et
du but de ces inscriptions anciennes
il s'agit d'un système d'écriture qui
comporte divers éléments reconnaissable
tels que des animaux des hommes des
fleurs des choses de la nature comme des
montagnes
le soleil la lune toute une série de
choses formant l'expérience humaine et
que l'on retrouve enfermé dans ses
heroes glyphes
cela nous révèle ce qui était important
à l'époque cela nous montre leur vision
du monde et ce qu'il pensait de
l'après-vie leur place dans l'univers
on y trouve le récit de leurs craintes
et leurs espoirs
en résumé les hiéroglyphes nous met en
relation avec la vie des égyptiens de
l'antiquité
grâce au déchiffrement de ses écrits de
l'egypte ancienne
on a pu découvrir des histoires
intéressantes et mystérieuse
les hiéroglyphes représente une des plus
grandes inventions des égyptiens de
l'antiquité qui les utilisaient pour
inscrire leurs craintes leurs espoirs
leurs rêves et les événements principaux
c'est remarquable écrit ont donné aux
experts des renseignements sur les
secrets cachés derrière les visages
préserver des momies cependant ils se
sont aperçus que les hiéroglyphes
présentait encore un problème on avait
leur signification
mais leur prononciation restait encore
mystérieuses en effet les hiéroglyphes
ne comprennent pas de voyelles
il s'agit probablement d'un des pires
systèmes d'écriture jamais inventée à
cause des choses qui sont dissimulés
cependant les hiéroglyphes ont un côté
fonctionnel et une beauté que l'on ne
trouve pas par exemple dans une écriture
alphabétique qui en général est écrite
dans une seule direction
au contraire on peut écrire les
hiéroglyphes de droite à gauche de
gauche à droite horizontalement ou
verticalement de telle sorte que le
résultat donne un effet visuel
intéressant tout en exprimant le message
contenu dans les hiéroglyphes les
hiéroglyphes sont similaires à la réal
architecture de l'antiquité
quand quelque chose c'était important il
se lancer dans des projets de grande
envergure pour mettre l'accent sur la
signification les hiéroglyphes n'y font
pas exception
les hiéroglyphes était utilisé pour ce
qui était officielle on les inscrivait
sur les bâtiments importants les grands
monuments certaines statues cependant
ils étaient les plus difficiles à
comprendre de tous les systèmes
d'écriture égyptien alors quand un
enfant apprenez à écrire il commençait
par l'écriture hiératique
hier à tiques s'est développé à peu près
à la même époque les hiéroglyphes vers
3100 avant jésus-christ il s'agissait
d'une cursive bien plus simple que les
hiéroglyphes et que l'on utilisait pour
les nécessités de la vie courante comme
par exemple les choses légales les
lettres où les contrats
en dépit de cette forme d'écriture
simplifier les experts pensent que 90 à
99 % de la population ne savez pas lire
y compris les artistes qui inscrivait
les hiéroglyphes
c'est à dire les scribes
je pense que beaucoup d'égyptiens qui
était même instruit du point de vue
pratique n'était pas capable de
comprendre tous les détails et de lire
le texte des hiéroglyphes
parce que ces derniers représentaient
une langue morte
c'est comme si les français du moyen âge
apprenez à écrire le latin à l'école
comme s'il parlait le latin vulgaire et
écrivait le latin classique
ainsi à l'époque où on écrivait encore
en hiéroglyphes
les gens ne parlaient pas la langue de
ces inscriptions
le fait de ne pas pouvoir lire les
hiéroglyphes posait un problème pour le
scribe et l'inciter à faire des erreurs
même de nos jours on peut trouver des
erreurs faites il ya bien longtemps dans
les hiéroglyphes inscrits sur de
nombreux murs
le système de corrélation entre les
écritures n'est pas automatique parce
que les signes ne correspondent pas il y
un système complet pour le hiératique et
un autre pour les hiéroglyphes sans
concours danse individuelle des signes
la création des hiéroglyphes été un
processus laborieux
le texte était tout d'abord écrit en
lira tic par une première personne puis
traduits du hiératique en hiéroglyphes
par une deuxième personne est finalement
corrigé par une troisième personne il y
avait ensuite le travail du sculpteur
qui était responsable de suivre les
instructions du scribe
après cela un autre scribe capable de
lire et est en charge de corriger les
erreurs du sculpteur
et puis on arrivait à la phase finale où
le peintre ajouter des couleurs aux
hiéroglyphes
l'impossibilité de lire les écrits
sacrés ne diminuait pas la croyance des
gens sans leur pouvoir les hiéroglyphes
avait ainsi un rôle religieux toth était
le dieu de l'écriture et était
représenté par un homme avec une tête
dit biz tenant à la main un stylet pour
les égyptiens de l'antiquité les
hiéroglyphes avait un pouvoir magique
tout comme les momies les tombes et les
statuts il joue un rôle important dans
la réalisation de l'immortalité
il y avait des formules magiques sur les
momies sur les bandelettes
il y en avait aussi sur les murs des
pyramides et sur les cercueils
on croyait que ces formules contenues
dans les hiéroglyphes assurer
l'accomplissement de leur demande par
exemple si j'écris sur mon cercueil que
le pharaon va m'accorder des milliers de
pins des milliers de pots de bière alors
c'est vrai ça se passe
les égyptiens pensaient que les
hiéroglyphes des formules pouvait
prendre vie de façon magique
cela constituait un problème ils se
souciaient de voir les oiseaux
s'envolent et où les créatures sortir
des cercueils
ce qui aurait pu ruminer l'effet des
formules ils ont donc quelques fois
écrit les hiéroglyphes de manière
incomplète
prenez par exemple le cas du dessin d'un
ce et rast un type de vipère avec deux
petites cornes sur la tête
c'est le serpent le plus dangereux
d'égypte ont dit en fait que si un
sera-ce vous pique il n'y a qu'une chose
à faire fumer une cigarette
ce symbole hiéroglyphique représentait
le son f
cependant c'était en même temps la
représentation de quelque chose de
réellement vivant un serpent dangereux
alors dans certaines périodes de
l'antiquité égyptienne on altérait les
hiéroglyphes en les coupant en deux pour
se protéger de la magie des dangers
représentés
les paroles contenues dans les
hiéroglyphes était destiné à aider la
momie tout en préservant le souvenir du
défunt l'homme
son corps est baissière mais les écrits
nous ferons ce souvenir lui il sera
divan dans la bouche de sottises papa et
reuze 1300 je suis sur ip
pour les egyptiens une des manières de
perpétuer leur vie consistait à
s'assurer que leurs noms étaient
inscrits et si possible de façon répétée
cela permettait de pallier à des
endommagements accidentelle ou peut être
intentionnelle par exemple si par malice
mon ennemi essayé après ma mort
d'enlever mon nom on peut alors trouvé
mon nom quelque part peut être caché en
dessous et je continue à exister
toutes formes d'écriture a
potentiellement et à mon avis sûrement
des implications magique
le nom ou le groupe de son que je le
prononce ou que je l'écrive sur un
morceau de papier vous le donne évoque
une image dans votre esprit cette image
représente la personne dont on a le nom
en conséquence le nom contient en
lui-même une partie de l'individu
pour les égyptiens les hiéroglyphes au
passé lointain et est une partie
essentielle de la préparation à la mort
dans cet endroit où on a vu apparaître
la première pyramide la pyramide de
saqqara il y avait de nombreux tombeaux
derrière l'aspect extérieur délabré de
sept tombes
certains des textes les plus anciens
survivent encore c'est hiéroglyphes son
de l'époque de l'ancien empire et datent
de 2006 ans avant jésus-christ
dans l'ancien empire il n'y avait ce que
l'on appelle le texte de pyramide qui
était réservé aux pharaons et qui
contenait toutes les formules provenant
probablement de sources très ancienne
mais ces textes n'étaient destinées
qu'aux pharaons pour le guider dans l'au
delà dans l'après vie il lui indiquer ce
qu'ils devaient dire là où ils devaient
aller et ce qu'il devait faire
c'est lui le souverain seigneur est sage
et illumine le ciré lô sur sept a pu
sentir exister pour le souverain le cas
présent où étaient réunis des essais
c'était frontières tout bouge canalini
grâce à son pouvoir
il fait ce qu'il veut et les listes
qu'il est et cela en tout dans le
royaume où ciel et à travers tout était
passé les dents
en 2000 avant jésus-christ pendant la
période du moyen empire il y a eu un
changement dans les hiéroglyphes les
formules que l'on ne trouvait que sur
les murs des tombeaux des pharaons ont
commencé à apparaître sur les cercueils
en bois de ce qu'ils pouvaient s'en
permettre la dépense
dans un sens on peut voir l'évolution
d'une certaine personnalisation des murs
des pyramides
on est passé à l' échelle plus humaine
du cercueil et plus encore aux rouleaux
de papyrus que l'on peut emporter avec
soi
ce rouleau de papyrus d'un 2500 avant
jésus-christ et est connue sous le nom
de livre des morts
le livre des morts tout comme les textes
des pyramides et des cercueils avaient
été créés pour permettre aux défunts de
passer sans danger dans l'au delà et ce
texte important et est souvent coûteux
quelqu'un de la bourgeoisie ou de la
haute bourgeoisie dépensé une bonne
somme d'argent à sa préparation pour
l'après vie il est intéressant de
remarquer qu'un rouleau de papyrus
vierge coûtait une partie modérée du
salaire mensuel d'un ouvrier
mais une fois décoré de textes et de
scènes du livre des morts
il coûtait la moitié du salaire annuel
si vous croyez vraiment que vous allez
vivre à jamais alors vous n'allez pas
mettre tout votre argent dans votre vie
sur terre
c'est l'après vie qui comptait le plus
alors ils mettaient leur fortune et
leurs efforts dans l'autre monde plutôt
que dans cette vie puisque sa durée
était plus longue
le livre des morts exposé en détail
l'idéologie de l'époque concernant l'au
delà
le livre des morts est une collection de
près de 200 formule magique
la copie la plus ancienne date de la
moitié du 15e siècle avant jésus-christ
mais selon les experts les formules
qu'elle contient rond nous a plus de
mille ans auparavant
pour les gens de l'antiquité c'était
comme une forme de protection écrite
conçu comme une défense et une aide
spirituelle
le jour des funérailles le livre des
morts été également ensevelies
il protégeait la momie à l'intérieur de
la tombe
la préparer pour son dernier voyage et
pour voiliers à tous ses besoins dans
l'au delà
c'est à dire qu'ils sont là pour être lu
par les défunts ils auraient été
destinées uniquement
on peut imaginer le défunt assis sur sa
tombe
déroulant le livre des morts je veux
dire par là que personne d'autre n'a les
lire le livre des morts
le livre des morts contenait des
renseignements cruciaux enfermé dans le
texte les secrets du voyage effrayant
vers l'au-delà pour les égyptiens
l'immortalité est l objectif principal
mais il aurait été difficile d'y
parvenir
tout cela est comparable au sommeil
quand vous dormez vous pouvez avoir des
cauchemars et d'une certaine façon les
égyptiens de l'antiquité imaginait que
le voyage du soleil à travers l'au delà
pendant la nuit était similaire au
voyage du défunt et représentait le pire
de tous les cauchemars
j'ai expliqué de manière fantaisiste que
les égyptiens de l'antiquité considéré
la mort comme si le défunt s'était
embarqué sur un bateau passant dans un
défilé montagneux les dangers arrivent
de tous les côtés
en fait l'image du serpent de la vie et
du passage en bateau
ce voyage sombre dans l'au delà et est
simplement la réflexion du voyage à
travers l'egypte où l'on trouvait
différentes entrées pour les diverses
régions pour aller du sud au nord par
exemple dasu ans à la méditerranée
c'était comme s'il au delà était
réfléchie ici bas grâce au livre des
morts les égyptiens essayer de maîtriser
leur crâne de façon magique
si on pouvait définir la mort alors elle
était moins effrayante
ils ont donc continué à éclaircir le
concept de l'au delà
cela faisait partie de l'évolution des
textes des pyramides et des cercueils
durant le moyen-âge pire quand les
formules étaient écrites sur les
cercueils
elle était accompagnée d'illustrations
ces dernières consistent est de carpes
aidant à guider le défunt pendant
l'étrange voyage de l'après vie
quand le nouvel empire a commencé le
texte a été séparée des cartes
le texte est devenu le livre des morts
et les cartes sont devenus le guide de
l'au delà
les deux éléments étaient mis dans la
tombe et comportaient tous deux des
écrits cependant il était différent
le guide de l'au-delà avait plus
d'illustrations et était divisé en
plusieurs livres intitulés par exemple
le livre des cavernes et le livre des
portes
il y à douze portes dans l'au delà
une par heure et chacune des portes
gardées par un serpent qui vous posent
des questions et vous devez savoir y
répondre correctement pour pouvoir
entrer par la porte et passer à la
suivante
en planifiant à l'avance les égyptiens
et s'est continuellement de répondre aux
questions concernant l'inconnu il ne
semblait pas vouloir de surprise quant à
cette aventure imaginaire et selon leur
description le voyage allait être
difficile
dans cet étrange domaine on pouvait voir
des hommes dont la tête était en flammes
d'autres noyées flottant sur l'eau et
des corps décapité les égyptiens avaient
une imagination vivid en ce qui concerne
la mort et en cela il n'était pas très
différent des autres cultures
c'était leur croyance qui les rangs des
marginaux
les égyptiens avaient de nombreuses
idées théologique concernant la vie
après la mort
elle était souvent contradictoires mais
toujours complémentaires
cela a donné de la profondeur à leur
religion et contrairement aux croyances
religieuses d'autres cultures
il y avait pour eux plusieurs choix ils
pouvaient choisir la théologie qui leur
convenait le mieux
et ils pouvaient en choisir plus d'une
on pense qu'on avait en fait des
échantillons de différentes compositions
qu'on monterait au propriétaire de la
tombe
on lui demandait ensuite ils préfèrent
une scène ou une autre et le faisait son
choix on pense que lorsque l'on peignait
les tombeaux on suivait un genre de
livre de modèles on peut voir d'après
les dessins que quelqu'un faisait tout
d'abord une esquisse en rouge qui
étaient ensuite corrigé par le maître en
noir les dessins étaient donc faits par
une équipe et non par une seule personne
cependant malgré toutes les options et
les efforts faits pour s'assurer
l'immortalité
il y avait encore une partie qui était
entièrement laissée à l'individu
c'était une croyance qui dataient
d'environ 2000 ans avant jésus-christ et
qui était de loin la plus importante
la vie des égyptiens menait à ce moment
à cette dernière étape à l'endroit connu
sous le nom de la salle du jugement
c'est là que les égyptiens étaient
questionnés et était responsable pour
leur action terrestre
c'est un peu comme le questionnaire pour
obtenir son permis de conduire aux états
unis on doit répondre à de nombreuses
questions mais si on ne réussit pas on
peut leur passer
et la prochaine fois ce sera plus facile
à cause du fait que vous connaissez les
questions et que vous avez eu le temps
de chercher les réponses
dans la salle du jugement le défunt
répondait donc à ces questions il niait
avoir commis de mauvaises actions tout
en récitant les paroles magiques du
livre des morts devant un tribunal de 40
de dieu cette étape portait le nom de
confession négative ou de déclarations
d'innocence
je connais le nom décalant de dieu
présent dans la salle à la justice et
qui fit de ce qui émane et les bois
valeur sans un jour de leur jugement car
la voici
je suis venu à la vous j'ai apporté les
régler et libre vous cherche des
mensonges je n'ai pas fait de grosses
sommes je n'ai pas ouvrir les associés
je n'ai pas remplacer la vérité car
l'erreur je n'ai pas fait de mal je n'ai
pas prêt je n'ai pas causer de blur jeu
n'est pas achevé
pendant que le défunt récitait la
formule on pesait son coeur qui étaient
considérés comme le centre de
l'intelligence en comparaison avec une
plume symbolisant l'idéal à atteindre
c'est là qu'on jugeait les actions
terrestres de la personne le défunt
devait à nouveau réciter une formule
particulière mais cette fois il ne
s'adressait pas au tribunal des dieux au
mur que j'ai reçu de manière neutre
contre moi ne soit pas un ennemi au tri
d'une heure ne soit pas un style en fait
rien devant le gardien de la balance car
tu es mon cas qui est à dire d'encore
nantes ou de mauvaises odeurs la torah
d'autres ne dribble pas de mensonges à
mon sujet présenté les yeux
si le curé la plume était de poids égal
la personne était libérée ensuite le
défunt était amenée par aux russes le
dieu des vivants devant osiris le dieu
des morts dans les reliefs égyptiens la
balance montre un équilibre mais il y a
toujours une chance
une crainte est une possibilité que ça
ne soit pas le cas
une des représentations classiques de ce
qui peut arriver consiste à ce que la
personne soit dévoré par une créature
mythologique qui se tient derrière la
balance et attend un repas pendant des
centaines et des milliers d'années parce
que tout le monde récite les formules
correct et ils sont tous des livres et
la créature est petite taille c'est un
mélange de lyon kipopo tam et de
crocodiles et on l'appelle la dévoreuse
quand vous êtes manger c'est la fin
absolue de votre existence
l'idée d'extinction était la plus grande
crainte des égyptiens et c'est grâce à
cela qu'ils ont pu maintenir l'ordre
dans leur société pendant des milliers
d'années il était restreint à la fois
par des lois terrestres et par celle de
l'inconnu
atteindre l'immortalité n'était pas
chose facile mais pour les égyptiens le
monde magique de l'eau dollars en valait
la peine
au cours de la longue histoire de la
civilisation de l'egypte ancienne
les croyances en la prési à montrer une
certaine évolution pendant
approximativement trois mille cinq cents
ans les hiéroglyphes ont été utilisés
pour inscrire le développement de ses
idées selon les experts les
renseignements provenant de l'ancien et
du moyen empire sont assez vague mais
dès le début du nouvel empire près de
1500 ans avant jésus-christ les
instructions données sont beaucoup plus
claires
pour les égyptiens il y avait une
destination finale après le mystérieux
voyage c'était une version améliorée du
monde qu'il connaissait c'était une
égypte idéalisé connu sous le nom
d'au-delà la croyance en la prairie
était acceptée par tous du cultivateur
le plus pauvre au plus puissant pharaon
à la fin selon leur religion
tous les gens seront égaux sans
différences sociales
ils seront tous en compagnie de cyril
leroy des morts et bénéficieront tous
d'une merveilleuse existence dans l'au
delà
il est difficile de définir exactement
ce que les égyptiens envisagé pour la
vie dans l'au delà
mais quand on regarde les scènes
représentées sur les murs des tombeaux
on voit des gens participant un grand
banquet qui jouent à des jeux et qui
écoutent de la musique
en fait on y voit toutes les choses que
l'on considère comme distraction
ce qui nous permet de penser que c'est
de cette manière qu'ils imaginaient l'au
delà
on peut trouver dans certaines
représentations de scènes 1 et à
idéaliser où on va à l'achat sur des
terrains humides rempli de gibier de
toutes sortes
il suffisait d'un bâton pour attraper
quelque chose et votre chat participez
également à la chasse de façon à obtenir
l'image d'une vie améliorée par rapport
à l'expérience terrestre grâce à cette
croyance en l'au-delà les égyptiens ont
apporté une certaine espérance où
normalement il n'y en aurait pas c'était
leur style de vie qui les incitaient à
l'imagination le résultat est un
haut-lieu d'abondance de facilité et par
dessus tout c'était un lieu où l'on
pouvait continuer son existence
livre des morts donnait les formules
magiques nécessaires permettant d'entrer
dans cet endroit parfait
vous at il aidé formule du champ des
autres grandes et les livres lus
commencement de la journée c'est la
liberté d'aller et de venir celle dont
le champ des gens qui se trouvent dans
le chemin des offrandes la halle à ce
niveau là la bosse là se trouve la
puissance ont pu isoler y récolter et y
manger on peut aussi travailler la leyre
et comme on le sait susciter d'élèves en
plus des formules magiques on peignait
sur les murs du tombeau et afin de
plaire aux dieux des scènes de la vie
que l'on désirait avoir dans l'au delà
ce sont des représentations des défunts
travaillant dans les champs
cependant il ne transpirait pas il
n'était pas sale
il n'était pas en haillons mais dans
leurs plus beaux atours
il était heureux il récoltait une sorte
de grains ou du blé qui était deux fois
plus haut que normal
les gens de l'antiquité considéré
l'egypte comme la plus grande de toutes
les civilisations et il ne voulait pas
l'abandonner
il était donc logique de mettre l'accent
sur la préparation précédant la mort
mais cela a mené à une confusion sur la
signification de tous leurs efforts
même aujourd'hui on a toujours
l'impression que les égyptiens étaient
préoccupés par la mort mais il ne
l'était pas c'est en fait leur passion
pour la vie qui les a amenés à de tels
extrêmes
sur les murs des tombeaux à côté des
représentations en couleur de l'eau de
là on peut trouver un autre type d'image
elles dépeignent la douleur des mesures
est causée par la mort
pour ce qui est du deuil et des
funérailles
si le défunt est un noble toutes les
femmes de la maison met de la boue sur
leur tête et leur visage et après avoir
laissé le corps du défunt dans la maison
elle marche dans les rues de la ville en
se frappant la poitrine et les hommes en
font de même
hérodote historiens de l'egypte ancienne
500 ans avant jésus-christ pour les
égyptiens il s'agissait de surmonter la
tristesse de la mort et la crainte qui
l'accompagnait en dépit de leur
description détaillée de l'eau dollars
il savait que c'était un territoire
inexploré alors en préparation et il
emballé tout
ils étaient prêts à toute éventualité
possible
imaginez que vous partiez pour un pays
dans lequel vous n'êtes jamais allé vous
allez emporter avec vous tout ce dont
vous aurez peut être besoin
les égyptiens suivait le même processus
de pensée alors qu'il faisait leurs
préparatifs pour l'après vie il ne
savait pas à quoi s'attendre dans l'au
delà
alors il se préparait à tout est emballé
tout ce dont ils pourraient avoir besoin
dans de nombreux tombeau on trouve un
genre de modèles représentant les choses
qu'un égyptien noble aimerait avoir dans
l'après vie ainsi il y aurait un grenier
des bateaux des serviteurs rendant
toutes sortes de services à leurs
maîtres
je pense qu'on imaginait que l'on
pourrait obtenir tout cela grâce aux
pouvoirs magiques des modèles même si le
défunt ne possédait aucune de ces choses
durant sa vie terrestre
les figurines les formules écrite en
hiéroglyphes
les guides de l'eau de l'un et les
peintures trouver sur les tombes montre
l'importance mise par l'égypte ancienne
sur la préparation pour la vie après la
mort
mais leurs efforts ne s'arrêtait pas là
à travers les âges les tombeaux de
l'élite égyptienne ont été considérés
comme les plus grands coffres à trésor
au monde et ils ont été convoités et
pillé à cause de leur grande valeur
cependant en dépit des vols de nombreux
objets ont survécu
y compris ceux trouvés durant ce qui
représente probablement la découverte la
plus fascinante du début du 20e siècle
l'excavation de la tombe de toutankhamon
c'est en 1922 à peu près à 5 km à
l'ouest de la ville moderne de louxor
dans la vallée des rois que l'on a fait
la découverte du tombeau d'un pharaon du
nom de toutankhamon un tronc de trois
mille deux cent soixante dix ans a été
découvert en egypte
on annonce la découverte la plus
sensationnelle du siècle de 1550 à 1070
avant jésus-christ la vallée des rois a
joué le rôle de cimetières pour la
plupart des pharaons du nouvel empire
cependant le problème de cet endroit
sacré réside dans le fait qu'il n'était
pas secret même pour les pilleurs de
l'antiquité
à travers les années la plupart des
richesses avait été pillé et de
nombreuses momies avaient été détruites
laissant l'endroit abandonné 2100 à 1070
avant jésus-christ
mais en novembre 1922 ce lieu sacré
réservé auparavant au défunt a repris
vie grâce à la découverte du tombeau de
toutankhamon qu'on a trouvé intacte
cette découverte constituera un apport
de grande valeur à la connaissance de
cette période
la nouvelle de cette découverte
d'importants suscitera l'intérêt du
monde entier pour les archéologues le
tombeau de toutankhamon était une
découverte exceptionnelle
on avait auparavant découverte d'autres
tombent mais jamais d'une telle
splendeur sur une surface d'environ 86
m² on avait pu préserver le passé
le souhait des égyptiens qu'on se
souvienne de leur vie bien après leur
mort s'accomplissait pour toutankhamon
qui était peut-être le septième
souverain enseveli ici
cette histoire rendra aussi longtemps
que l'excavation il s'agissait d'un des
plus grands trésors la momie d'un
souverain de l'antiquité trouvé grâce à
la ténacité d'un archéologue du nom de
our quart d'heure
hao de carter était né en
grande-bretagne en 1874 son niveau
d'instruction était limité mais ses
talents d'artiste lui ont permis d'aller
en egypte à l'âge de 17 ans carter a été
invité à copier des croquis de scènes
trouver sur des tombes
c'est là que son intérêt pour l'egypte
ancienne et l'archéologie a commencé
dès 1900 il était l'inspecteur général
en haute egypte ce qui comprenait la
vallée des rois
cependant les droits d'excavation appelé
concession était entre les mains de
théodore davis un avocat américain à la
retraite depuis 1902
théodore davis a pu persuader le chef du
service des antiquités qu'il serait une
bonne chose de travailler dans la vallée
des rois
awad carter est devenu en charge de
superviser le travail ce qui lui
permettait de ne pas travailler seuls
carter a pu ainsi se faire une idée plus
précise de la vallée des rois etc douter
qu'il y avait sûrement des tombes qui
n'avait pas été découverte et qui était
peut-être encore intacte
la collaboration de carter avec davis
n'a duré que deux ans carter a reçu une
promotion et a été transféré à saqqara
alors que davis et son équipe sont
restés dans la vallée des rois et ont
continué à creuser le terrain pendant
une autre décennie à la recherche de
trésors cachés pendant cette période
davis a découvert des objets appartenant
au tombeau d'un pharaon disparu depuis
longtemps il était évident que ces
objets appartenaient à toutankhamon car
son nom se trouvait sur l'un d'entre eux
il s'agissait d'un chaland l'un comporte
en son nom et la date de son règne
son nom apparaissait aussi sur des
plafonds en bout et comme cachet sur des
couvercles de boue ferment des amphores
dès 1909 davis était convaincu d'avoir
trouvé les restes du tombeau royal de
toutankhamon et à cette époque carter ne
travaillait plus à saqqara
en 1905 carter avait laissé son poste
prestigieux après une dispute avec des
touristes pendant plusieurs années il
avait essayé de gagner sa vie en tant
qu'artiste et quelquefois négociant
d'art égyptien
il était ensuite devenu le partenaire de
l'ofppt carnaval un anglais fortunés à
la constitution frêle possédant une
passion pour l'egypte ancienne
rudyard kipling a décrit la vie de
l'archéologue en disant cela fournit une
recherche intellectuelle accompagné de
l'aventuré exaltante de la vie du
chercheur d'or
cela explique pourquoi lord carnavon n
était disposé à dépenser tant d'argent
et tant d'années à la recherche d'un
tombeau de la vallée des rois qui
auraient échappé aux pilleurs
un bronze lansing 1923 carter et
carnaval avait fait plusieurs
découvertes publié en 1912 mais il
convoitait la concession de davis la
vallée des rois
en 1915 le rêve est devenu réalité quand
davis a abandonné son travail dans la
vallée étant certain qu'il n'y avait pas
de trésors à découvrir
je crains d'avoir épuisé les ressources
de la vallée des tombes théodore davis
malgré l' enthousiasme de carter et
carnaval ces derniers ont dû reporter
leurs travaux sur leur nouvelle
concession quand la première guerre
mondiale a éclaté
carnaval était en angleterre alors que
carter servait de liens diplomatiques en
egypte
il est resté en egypte pendant la guerre
et à continuer les recherches
ce qui lui a permis d'acquérir une bonne
connaissance de la vallée il était donc
convaincu de l'existence d'autres
tombent mais il n'avait aucune idée de
l'endroit où elles pouvaient se trouver
pendant la guerre carter a développé une
stratégie d'excavation il a pensé à
dégager l'air complète de la vallée
jusqu'à la couche rocheuse de façon à
trouver l'entrée d'un tombeau s'il y en
avait un
certains experts pensent qu'il a aussi
pris en considération les objets trouvés
durant la découverte de davis en 1912 et
qui s'était avérée faire partie du
tombeau de toutankhamon
il était commun en egypte d'enterrer des
objets de ce genre qui étaient liés à
ceux de la tombe près de cette dernière
carter a donc utilisé ce lieu comme
indice de l'endroit possible du tombeau
de toutankhamon
il a ensuite pu faire une carte de la
vallée entière et examiner la partie
centrale qui n'avait pas été
soigneusement étudiés cela l'a amené à
la conclusion que le tombeau de
toutankhamon se trouvait probablement
dans une petite aire triangulaire qui
n'avait jamais fait l'objet
d'explorations archéologiques
dès 1917 carter carnaval n'était libre
de commencer leur travail dans la vallée
des rois
après cinq longues et coûteuses années
sans résultat
carnaval voulait arrêter l'excavation
mais carter toujours déterminée a fait
une offre à son partenaire que ce
dernier ne pouvait refuser
carter a proposé de financer lui-même
une saison supplémentaire de recherche
tout en rendant carnaval qui était le
propriétaire de la concession
bénéficiaires de tout ce qui allait être
excavées on n'est pas certain que carter
et carnavalet et parlé de la possibilité
de trouver le tombeau de toutankhamon
cependant carter a été direct avec
carnaval et carnaval a répondu non non
non mon garçon seymour et qui perd est
encore une saison et ce sera tout le 1er
novembre 1922 carton à recommencer les
travaux dans la vallée des rois
cela n'a pris que trois jours pour
découvrir le haut d'un escalier dès le
quatrième jour l'air avaient été dégagés
et on pouvait apercevoir 12 marches
menant à une porte en dessous de la
couche rocheuse
le style datait de la xviiie dynastie
est ce que c'était le tombeau d'un noble
enseveli ici par permission royal
s'agissait-il d'un endroit où on avait
caché une momie et ses objets funéraires
pour raisons de sécurité
ou est-ce que c'était en fait le tombeau
du pharaon que je cherchais depuis tant
d'années hao de cartes
le 6 novembre 1922 c'est à dire le 5e
jour de l'excavation carter a envoyé un
télégramme
un carnaval
enfin effet découvertes fantastiques
dans vallée ton magnifique est intacte
trouver le jour de votre arrivée
félicitations
environ trois semaines plus tard
carnaval est arrivé en egypte avec sa
fille evelyne le lendemain le 24
novembre 1922
le travail a commencé ils ont d'abord
dégager l'entrée qui se trouvaient en
bas des escaliers
ils ont ensuite enlevé le calcaire pu
bloquer le corridor ce blocage datait de
l'antiquité et était destinée à arrêter
les voleurs
dès le 26 novembre le corridor avait été
vidé et on pouvait apercevoir une autre
porte
carter a placé une bougie dans la pièce
au delà de la porte et a pu observer
l'intérieur
tout d'abord je ne pouvais rien voir de
l'air chaud s'est échappé de la pièce
mes yeux se sont ensuite habitués à la
lumière et certains détails de la pièce
ont commencé à émerger de l'ensemble des
animaux étranges des statuts et de l'or
qui brille est partout je suis resté
bouche bée
et quand leur carnaval n'a plus pu
supporter le suspense il a demandé avec
impatience on veut vous voir quelque
chose oui des choses étonnantes
finalement le 25 novembre 1922 c'était
bien le tombeau de toutankhamon que l'on
avait trouvé et son excavation s'avèrera
aussi fascinante que sa découverte
le 29 novembre 1922
les chercheurs sont officiellement
entrés dans le tombeau de toutankhamon
une fois à l'intérieur ils ont prouvé
que l'endroit était inhabituel pour un
pharaon égyptien
contrairement à beaucoup d'autres tombes
de la même période celle de toutankhamon
était petit
les décorations figurant sur des plans
de la même époque qu'on avait découvert
auparavant avait été abandonné ce qui a
amené les experts à penser que
toutankhamon était mort prématurément
il est probable qu'à l'origine le
tombeau avait été construit pour
quelqu'un d'autre
on l'avait donc utilisé à la hâte pour
toutankhamon pour de nombreuses raisons
c'était un cas exceptionnel restée
intacte à cause des structures et des
projets de construction situé au dessus
il avait été ainsi laissé dans
l'obscurité pendant longtemps
la maison de l'éternité de toutankhamon
s'était enfoncé dans la montagne
montrant à la civilisation moderne que
la vallée des rois était un endroit sûr
pour dissimuler un pharaon ainsi que
tous les trésors dont il avait besoin
dans l'autre monde
cependant selon les experts ce n'était
pas un secret pour les voleurs de
l'antiquité les objets qui avait été
placé correctement par les prêtres et
les participants aux funérailles était
en désordre
on avait pu remarquer les vols et les
prêtres avaient remis autant d'objets
que possible à leur place il était tout
de même clair qu'on n'était pas très
soucieux de restaurer les pièces du
tombeau dans leur état d'origine
ce que l'on pouvait voir à présent était
le résultat d'un nettoyage rapide après
les vols
certains experts pensent que les voleurs
ont été arrêtés avant de vraiment
commencer
en conséquence quand carter a commencé
ces excavations du tombeau connu sous le
nom de king valait numéro 62 ou caves et
62 de nombreux objets funéraire de
toutankhamon était toujours présent il
n'avait aucune idée de qui il était de
la durée de son règne de son âge en
enlevant les objets du tombeau ils ont
commencé à avoir des indices indiquant
qu'il ne pouvait pas avoir eu de 18 ans
lors de sa mort
en fait un des premiers indices trouvés
par les chercheurs qui montrait que
toutankhamon était un pharaon encore
enfant consistait d'un gant trouvé dans
la première section du tombeau la petite
taille du gant leur a montré que le
pharaon était probablement mort avant
d'avoir atteint l'âge adulte
on pense que toutankhamon est mort entre
18 et 19 ans après un règne d'une durée
de 9 ans qui avait commencé en 1333
avant jésus-christ
il était né pendant la xviiie dynastie
et était le fils d'un pharaon dont
l'identité reste encore inconnu
comme beaucoup de faits de l'époque une
grande partie de la vie de toutankhamon
restent mystérieuses mais même le temps
n'a pas pu annihiler l'importance de
certaines des réalisations qu'il a
accompli durant son règne sur l'egypte
on diminue trop souvent le rôle de
toutankhamon parce qu'il était enfant et
on le considère comme un pharaon sans
importance dans l'histoire de la
civilisation égyptienne
si vous voulez dire qu'il n'a pas régné
pendant 67 ans comme ramsès ou 54 ans
comme tout mot 6 3
si vous voulez dire qu'il n'a pas fait
de grandes campagnes pour s'accaparer
des parties importantes du monde
vous avez raison mais c'est quelqu'un
qui a restauré l'ordre dans l' empire
après l'hérésie d'akhenaton
akhenaton était le prédécesseur de
toutankhamon et peut être même son père
il est célèbre pour sa croyance en un
seul dieu at-on représentant un des
aspects du soleil at on est représenté
dans les reliefs égyptiens par un cercle
qui projette des rayons de lumière et
qui finit dans des mains donnant la vie
au roi et à la reine la fois d'akhenaton
en un seul dieu a dont était un culte
étrange pour les égyptiens de l'époque
mais il a été imposé pendant le règne de
ce pharaon
le dieu de bonté le seul venant de
rennes dont la perfection à modeler
attendons utile fidèle à son créateur
qui le sert qui l'a engendré qui
quittent pour lui le pays qui l'a mis
sur le trône qui exhale taton qui loue
son nom qui fait que le pays appartient
à son créateur
inscriptions de l'egypte ancienne
la plus grande partie de la vie dates
ont été consacrés à des constructions
dédié à son dieu et à la démolition de
celle qui existait auparavant il avait
amené un nouvel ordre qui sera abandonné
au profit de l'ancien camp toutankhamon
âgé de 19 ans montera sur le trône
on a donc activement restaurer les
temples des dieux effet de nouvelles
statues de ces divinités toutes ces
choses avaient été détruites durant le
règne d'akhenaton
c'était en conséquence une préoccupation
majeure du règne suivant il fallait
réinstaurer le système religieux avec
des représentations des dieux au centre
du culte pratiqués dans les temples
l'importance du règne de toutankhamon
fait souvent l'objet de débats certains
experts pensent qu'il y a des preuves
évidentes à l'intérieur de son tombeau
qui suggère que les gens de l'époque a
prouvé son effort de reconstruction
je fais partie de ceux qui pensent que
son tombeau comportait de nombreuses
richesses à cause du fait que c'était en
son nom que l'on a initié la
restauration des cultes
c'était entre autres pour montrer de
l'appréciation pour sa restauration des
cultes
on sait que certains des objets du
tombeau de toutankhamon n'avait pas été
fait pour ses funérailles
ils avaient été fabriquées pour un autre
ou pour plusieurs autres pharaon est
gardé en réserve
on les avait apporté et on avait changé
les noms inscrits pour les utiliser pour
toutankhamon le tombeau contenait des
milliers d'objets certains étaient des
dons faits aux pharaons et d'autre des
choses utiliser de son vivant tout le
monde était ébahie par les richesses
trouvé pendant la découverte
cependant l'élément le plus précieux
n'étaient pas sans valeur artistique
le 16 février 1923 trois mois après être
entré dans le tombeau du pharaon
on a annoncé que le corps de
toutankhamon se trouvaient à l'intérieur
pour carter et carnaval c'était un
moment inoubliable
cependant il sera de courte durée pour
carnaval
après la découverte de la momie il y a
eu des disputes au sujet de la
répartition des objets selon le
gouvernement égyptien
si le tombeau était intact il pouvait
empêcher les chercheurs de garder les
objets excavées
pendant cette période carter et carnaval
n'était pas d'accord sur la manière
d'affronter les difficultés résultant de
la découverte
puis le 23 février carter a mis carnaval
à l'apport et lui a dit de ne jamais
revenir
ce sera leur dernière dispute
le 28 février carnaval est allé à swan
pour se reposer c'est là qu'il a été
piqué par un moustique au visage
il s'est ensuite rasé ce qui lui a
provoqué une infection sans pouvoir se
procurer d'antibiotiques l'état de
carnaval c'est tout d'abord améliorer
puis cet empire et le 5 avril 1923
carnaval est mort tout en donnant
naissance à une des légendes les plus
célèbres rois
une femme écrivain de l'époque a déclaré
qu'elle avait dit à lord carnavon de
faire attention aux croyances mystiques
des égyptiens et elle a expliqué qu'elle
n'était pas surprise de voir des
accidents arrivent et aux explorateurs
qui osaient pénétrer les tombeaux des
souverains
à cause de circonstances dramatiques de
la situation les gens ont évoqué l'idée
de l'existence d'une malédiction dont il
était le premier à subir les effets
selon la superstition celui qui pénètre
le tombeau d'un souverain est maudit en
conséquence la maladie du lord était
considéré comme l'accomplissement de
cette légende ancienne
mais bien sûr si vous considérez tous
les gens qui faisait partie de la
découverte
vous remarquerez que la malédiction agi
d'une manière étrangement lente
la malédiction de toutankhamon a pris
naissance dans l'imagination des gens
qui étaient présents à l'ouverture du
tango qui ne pouvaient pas avoir accès à
la tombe
elle n'avait pas de choses importantes à
faire ils ont donc inventé une
malédiction toutankhamon a peut être
envoyé son âme pour tuer celui qui l'a
trouvé la malédiction du pharaon entoure
son tombeau elle n'est pas fondée sur
une inscription ou un objet du tombeau
les malédictions égyptienne existe mais
celle ci n'est pas véritable c'est une
fraude
la malédiction n'était peut-être rien de
plus qu'une histoire de fantômes tel
qu'on en trouve encore aujourd'hui mais
elle faisait partie du folklore qui
entourait le pharaon et suscitait
toujours la crainte même en 1972 quand
on a fait une exposition sur
toutankhamon au prestigieux british
museum
c'est un fait qui n'est pas connu mais
quelques semaines avant le début de
l'exposition un des organisateurs est
mort subitement cela ne s'est pas passé
au musée son décès a eu lieu ailleurs
mais les gens étaient pris d'inquiétude
y compris ceux qui comme nous
travaillaient dans le musée on a alors
demandé à l'équipe de ne rien mentionné
à personne parce qu'ils médiatement les
genres et 10 à la malédiction
personnellement je n'ai eu aucune
anxiété en m'occupant des objets enfin
je me souciais surtout donne pas les
faire tomber
je ne pensais pas à la malédiction
ça fait déjà 23 ans et je fais toujours
bien
carter n'a pas accordé d'importance à la
malédiction et en a plus tard exprimé le
regret
les sentiments ressentis par
l'égyptologue ne sont pas une forme de
crainte mais du respect et de
l'admiration
c'est tout à fait l'opposé d'une
superstition insensé on a déclaré qu'il
y avait de véritables dangers cachés
dans le tombeau de toutankhamon
une sorte de force mystérieuse appelée à
se manifester pour se venger de ceux qui
oseraient entrer dans l'endroit il n'y a
probablement aucun autre endroit au
monde où il existe aussi peu de risque
que dans cette tombe
pendant la décennie qui a suivi l'année
1922 carter a dédié son temps à excaver
et conserver des milliers d'objets à
chaque excavation il y avait des
renseignements supplémentaires au sujet
du pharaon et particulièrement de sa
momie
le tombeau de toutankhamon était là 433e
découverte de howl carter depuis 1915
ni lui ni personne d'autre n'avait
jamais vu quelque chose de similaire
auparavant
c'est si impressionnant je n'ai jamais
rêvé de voir quelque chose de pareil
l'antichambre du tombeau du pharaon
était encore remplies d'objets
magnifiques
la pièce était dans l'état où on l'avait
laissée quand on l'avait fermée à
l'époque de l'antiquité
james hendry brest et
de nombreux objets précieux étaient
entassés dans l'espace des quatre pièces
et carter a pris soin d'assurer la
sécurité de chacun d'entre eux il y
avait tant d'objets qu'il était
difficile d'en bouger un sans risquer
d'endommager d'autres dans certains cas
ils étaient emmêlés de manière
inextricable de telle sorte que l'on a
dû créer un système de support de façon
à pouvoir tenir un objet ou un groupe d'
objet pendant qu'on en enlever un autre
round carte les tombes voisines avait
été converti en salle obscure de
conservation alors que l'on était tous
les objets qui étaient ensuite étudié
par une équipe de spécialistes venus de
divers pays
carter et son équipe ont documenté
patiemment et ont aidé à la préservation
de cette énorme quantité d'objets
anciens dont le gouvernement égyptien
avait réclamé les droits exclusifs
depuis 1925
dès la mi février 1923 l'antichambre
avaient été dégagés à l'exception de
deux statues de cas fait à l'image de
toutankhamon
comme tant d'autres statues de l'egypte
ancienne elle avait un but spécifique
elle pouvait agir pour la momie si cette
dernière subissaient des dégâts de
quelque sorte
et elle servait de gardien de la chambre
funéraire
il est intéressant de remarquer qu'avant
le décès de carnaval et avant
l'ouverture officielle du tombeau le 17
février 1923 carter et carnaval avait
succombé à la curiosité
sur cette photo on peut voir entre les
deux statues à taille humaine un panier
accroché au mur
le panier avait été mis là par les deux
chercheurs pour cacher un trou qu'ils
avaient fait prématurément dans le mur
pour voir la pièce qui se trouvait
derrière le frère de carnaval merveille
rob huff a décrit la nervosité de son
frère pendant l'ouverture officielle du
tombeau
le pauvre vieillard était nerveux comme
un petit écolier espiègle craignant
qu'on découvre qu'un trou avait déjà été
fait il était aussi naturellement rempli
d'entousiasme ses connaissances lui
permettait de savoir approximativement
ce qu'on allait trouver mais il ne
pouvait s'empêcher de penser que ce
genre de moments extraordinaires
n'arrive qu'à très peu de gens
malheureusement carnaval ne partagera
pas la joie de carter à explorer la
chambre funéraire car il est mort moins
de six mois après le début de
l'excavation
la chambre funéraire contenait plus de
300 objets mais aucun égalait le
cercueil doré qui éclairait presque la
pièce entière
il y en avait un dans un autre puis dans
un autre et encore dans un autre
au total il n'y en avait 4 mai ils
étaient secondaires par rapport aux
trésors qu'ils renfermaient
avec une émotion intense j'ai enlevé les
boulons du dernier cercueil et j'ai
ouvert les panneaux doucement en lui
tournant et la remplissant l'intérieur
se trouvait à nîmes en sarcophage jaune
intacte dont le couvercle était toujours
en place et qui était dans l'état où des
pieuses mains laver ni hao de cartes
le sarcophage avait été taillé dans un
bloc de pierre massif mais carter à
penser que le couvercle était
probablement un remplacement de
l'original selon les experts cela montre
encore que les préparatifs funéraire de
toutankhamon avait été fait rapidement
il était aussi intéressant de constater
que le couvercle du sarcophage était
fêlée marquant la pierre délicatement
payet on dirait qu'il y avait eu un
accident pendant les funérailles
les artisans avait peut-être fait tomber
le couvercle en essayant de bougies le
sarcophage dans un espace aussi réduit
et il n'avait pas eu le temps de le
réparer complètement
on a l'impression qu'ils se sont
dépêchés de le réparer un peu avant de
le remettre en place et on a remarqué
récemment que le sarcophage avait été
altéré avant d'être utilisées pour les
funérailles de toutankhamon
on voit à présent des inscriptions et
des personnages divin sur l'extérieur du
buste mais à l'origine il y avait une
couche différentes et si vous regardez
de près vous verrez des traces des
décorations précédente
cela a donné lieu à un certain nombre de
théories suggérant que le sarcophage
avait peut-être été fait pour quelqu'un
d'autre
carter a soulevé le couvercle du
sarcophage presque un an jour pour jour
après l'ouverture officielle du tombeau
le couvercle s'est ouvert facilement et
au début on a vu qu'un espace long et 3
et sombre
l'espace ombre a permis bientôt de
découvrir un cercueil doré qui s'avérera
être le premier d'une série de trois
en utilisant les manettes se trouvant
sur les côtés on a soulevé le couvercle
et on a découvert un autre cercueil
ensuite carter a enlevé le deuxième
couvercle et le troisième est finalement
on a pu voir le dernier serveur
devant nous se trouvait une
impressionnante momies qui avait été
fait soigneusement et qui occupait tout
l'intérieur du cercueil doré
et puis il ya eu un moment d'émotion
incomparable quand les chercheurs ont
remarqué que la tête de la momie était
couvert par un des trésors les plus
spectaculaires
le masque de toutankhamon
les égyptiens pensaient que si tout se
passait bien durant le voyage final le
défunt pourrait vivre avec les dieux et
dans ce cas le but du masque était de
mettre l'accent sur les attributs divins
du défunt grâce à une inscription faite
au dos de l'objet et provenant du livre
des morts dans cette inscription
on voit que les éléments variés de la
tête du défunt les yeux le nez les
oreilles les sources y sont tous comparé
à travers le masque avec les éléments
correspondant sur le corps de différents
dieux
le but de ce procédé est d'amener le
défunt dans la sphère divine pour en
faire un dieu grâce à l'association des
différentes parties de son corps avec
celle de toute une série de divinités
qui se préoccupent d'accomplir la
résurrection
ton un droit l avare nocturne ton oeil
gauche et la barque urnes
tu es sourd s'ils sont des aînés a eu le
dessus de la tête et anibis le derrière
de ta tête et horus t doit son top
rae a entendu ton nom est tu as été
justifiées office da torre est à tête ne
sera jamais enlevé réussite en paix
les gens de l'époque avaient fait de
leur mieux pour préparer le pharaon à
subir cette dernière transformation
cependant le tombeau de toutankhamon
comportaient certains problèmes
particulièrement en ce qui concerne la
momie il était très important pour
harper d'enlever lui même les
bandelettes de la momie il voulait
trouver une preuve de l'âge auquel
toutankhamon était mort il voulait aussi
chercher des indices sur les relations
familiales du souverain avec d'autres
pharaon de la xviiième dynastie la
presse mondiale était centrée sur les
mêmes impératifs
tout le monde voulait voir le visage de
toutankhamon
carter a essayé d'extraire le corps mais
en vain parce que des huiles avaient été
versés à l'intérieur pour protéger la
momie carter a donc dû à contrecoeur
couper le corps en plusieurs morceaux
pour le sortir du sarcophage ce qui a
permis le filmage
la partie finale du rip consistait à
versé des litres d'huile sacré dans ce
cas sur toutankhamon
ce qui a bien endommagé la momie en
conséquence quand on a fait l'autopsié
de la momie de toutankhamon
elle était en très mauvais état
les huiles avait aussi fait adhérer
fermement le masque de toutankhamon à
son visage alors on a dû séparer sa tête
du masque en utilisant des couteaux
chaud quand on a pu libérer son visage
le pharaon toutankhamon est finalement
apparu le jeune pharaon était enfin là
devant nous
c'était le sommet de nos longues
recherches
le tombeau avait donné son secret le
message du passé avait atteint le
présent en dépit du temps et de
l'érosion de tant d'années à aude corde
après avoir enlevé la momie de
toutankhamon du cercueil
on a déroulé avec soin ses bandelettes
sous les couches de l'ain on a trouvé
plus de 110 joue dans l'antiquité il
était considéré comme magique et était
destiné à aider toutankhamon pendant son
difficile voyage dans l'au delà
mais ce n'est pas la seule forme de
magie que l'on a pu trouver dans le
tombeau il y avait des objets dans le
tombeau que personne n'avait vu
auparavant et dont le but reste encore
obscur aujourd'hui il y avait un très
beau vase et je me suis souvent demandé
s'il avait un pouvoir magique
c'était un vase en albâtre qui ne
comporte aucune peinture sur l'extérieur
il n'y a rien de pain l'intérieur mais
si vous y mettez une source de lumière
un portrait de toutankhamon et akhénaton
appareils cela devait sembler magique
en dépit de la rapidité avec laquelle la
préparation du tombeau de toutankhamon
avait été fait
on avait beaucoup fait pour la
transformation finale du pharaon
il y avait des bateaux de taille réduite
des repose tête des jeux des instruments
des armes
des chaises
des colliers des vases
des coffrets des bracelets un trône et
même des petites statues représentant
des serviteurs et que l'on appelle ou
chat petit
ces petites statues étaient censés
prendre votre place dans l'au delà
si vous étiez appelés à travailler la
statue répondait pour vous et c'est pour
cela qu'on les nomme
ouch à petit c'est à dire répondant si
on vous appelez la petite statue se
levait disait présent toutankhamon
avaient été ensevelis avec des centaines
de ses statuts ainsi il n'aurait jamais
à travailler dans l'autre monde
il semble que le tombeau de toutankhamon
a été préparé par les égyptiens en
suivant les croyances en l'au delà
pendant plus de dix ans carter a essayé
de préserver tout leur travail y compris
la momie du souverain
j'ai fait le nécessaire pour qu'on
laisse à jamais son corps dans le
sarcophage son lieu de repos
jusqu'à ce jour le souhait de out carter
a été respectée dans le site cave et 60
de plus de 3000 ans après ses
funérailles
la momie de toutankhamon repose dans sa
maison de l'éternité
ce tombeau a peut être été considérée
comme la plus grande découverte du xxème
siècle jusqu'à maintenant
à quelques pas du tombeau de
toutankhamon se trouve le site kinks
valait numéro 5 ou une excavation est en
cours
en mai 1995 dans la vallée des rois un
tombeau connu depuis longtemps à
susciter l'intérêt du public
plus de soixante dix ans après
l'étonnante découverte de toutankhamon
fait brown carter l'imagination du
public étaient captivés par des
nouvelles provenant d'égypte
encore une fois la civilisation disparue
promettait de révéler un peu plus au
sujet de son passé grâce à l'excavation
en cours du site kinks valait numéro 5
ou plutôt qu'à v5
l'existence de cave et cinq avaient été
remarquées depuis l'époque de son
premier visiteur james burton un
explorateur anglais qui en avait
commencé l'excavation en 1825 à l'époque
le tombeau avait été bloquée du sol au
plafond par des débris d'inondations
mais burton avait pu y entrer et avait
fait des esquisses de tout ce qu'ils
avaient pu voir c'est à dire
principalement le haut de la tombe puis
en 1902 il ya eu un autre visiteur out
carter carter pensait que le tombeau
était petit et sans importance il a donc
abandonné l'exploration utilisant la
colline surplombant pour déverser les
débris d'un autre projet
grâce à carter qu'avait 5 est restée
ensevelie sous plus de trois mètres de
débris rocheux jusqu'en 1987
c'est alors qu'une équipe d'archéologues
qui travaillait dans l'endroit a
commencé à l'ex cavée
pour compléter leur travail il essayait
de retrouver l'entrée avant de voir le
gouvernement égyptien exécuter son
projet d'agrandissement de la route
utilisée par les autocars de tourisme ce
qui aurait pu endommager le tombeau en
quelques jours de travail
il avait exposé l'entrée et utiliser
l'espace par lequel burton s'était
lui-même introduit dans le tombeau
et voilà la première pièce à environ 3
mètres de long 3 mètres 60 de large et
deux mètres 70 de haut elle est remplie
de débris d'inondations jusqu'à environ
cinq centimètres du plafond ces débris
s'écoule dans le tombeau à peu près tous
les deux cents ans quand il pleut dans
la vallée des rois
après avoir pu entrer les archéologues
ont passé les six années suivantes à
dégager les deux premières pièces et
finalement qu'avait 5 a révélé son
histoire sur les murs il y avait des
décorations qui avait été endommagé par
une fuite dans les égouts situé au
dessus les textes s'était effrité mais
certains des reliefs était encore intact
montrant le plus grand pharaon de
l'histoire de l'egypte
ramsès 2 alors qu'il présentait ses fils
défunt odieux
à ce moment là le site café 5 s'est
avéré plus important contrairement à ce
que james burton et aw carter avait
imaginé à l'origine
alors que l'on à creuser plus
profondément dans les débris
on a trouvé sur le sol d'une des pièces
des milliers de morceaux de poteries des
centaines de fragments de bijoux des
fragments de statues des sarcophages des
cannes ap toutes sortes de reste mais
tout cela montre clairement que le
tombeau avait été utilisé pour les fils
de ramsès 2 au cours des six ans après
avoir dégagé les deux premières pièces
nous avons remarqué que même la deuxième
pièce était décoré et on a trouvé de
plus en plus d'inscriptions pourtant les
noms des fils du pharaon pendant l'hiver
1994 1995
les archéologues ont commencé une
nouvelle excavation du tombeau pour
chercher au delà des deux premières
pièces
ils ont trouvé une autre pièce
comportant seize pilier et un couloir au
fond ce qui leur permettait de voir
qu'il y avait encore bien plus à
découvrir grâce à cette excavation
fantastique
dès 10 heures du matin le 2 février 1995
on avait dégager les débris bloquant le
couloir du fonds les archéologues
n'avaient plus à utiliser l'entrée fait
par burton il pouvait sortir de la
troisième pièce par un corridor qui
était d'une longueur de 30 mètres
qu'avez 5 était énorme
je pense que notre première réaction
était mon dieu ce n'est pas possible
nous étions trois ce jour là dans le
tombeau et en voyant cela pour la
première fois nous n'arrêtions pas de
dire je ne peux pas le croire
ce n'est pas possible je n'arrive pas à
le croire
le corridor était en forme de t et des
deux côtés il y avait deux corridors de
plus qui contenait environ 50 pièces
servant de chapelle à offrandes pour les
prêtres de l'antiquité
à l'intersection de ces couloirs il y
avait un relief dans la pierre
représentant clairement osiris dont la
tête était tombé depuis longtemps au
cours de l'excavation il est devenu
évident que le tombeau avait été pillée
pendant l'antiquité mais depuis 2500 ans
qu'avait 5 avait pu garder ses secrets
les archéologues et des prix
d'étonnement devant un tel spectacle
c'est le plus grand tombeau de la vallée
des rois et probablement d'égypte son
plan est unique
la plupart des tombeaux de la vallée ont
des corridors qui s'enfonce directement
dans la colline mais le plan de celui là
et comme celui d'un labyrinthe comme une
pieuvre avec des tentacules qui vont
dans toutes les directions
c'est le premier exemple de mausolée
familial dans l'histoire de l'egypte
les archéologues sont certain qu'au
moins quatre des fils de ramsès ii ont
été enterrés là et peut-être même 40 80
où il pense aussi qu'il ya des chambres
funéraires sous les couloirs soutenant
les chapelles à offrandes
l'excavation continue et expliquera
peut-être quand pourquoi et pour qui le
tombeau a été construit ce qui se trouve
à l'intérieur demeure un mystère qui
sera peut être résolue dans la décennie
qui vient
mais seul l'avenir nous le dira
pour l'instant la découverte en
elle-même suffi à donner de l'espoir à
ceux qui sont à la recherche d'un
lointain passé
tout le monde pensait qu'on en avait
fini avec la vallée des rois que l'on
savait tout et que la découverte du
tombeau de toutankhamon fait part à hu
carter avait marqué la fin on pouvait
donc tous rentrés chez nous il n'y avait
rien d'autre à trouver les 73 ans plus
tard nous avons prouvé que tout cela
était fou et je ne pense pas que la fin
soit proche un endroit aussi explorer
que la vallée des rois est toujours
remplie de surprises et cela pourrait
mener à des changements majeurs dans ce
que l'on connaît au sujet de l'égypte
ancienne
qu'avait 5
toutankhamon
les hiéroglyphes
les pyramides
le suspense
et les momies nous raconte l'histoire de
l'egypte ancienne
c'était un pays où l'imagination se
mêlait à l'intellect la religion se
mélanger à la mythologie et où les idées
abstraites former la base de la réalité
sous tant d'aspects l'egypte demeure
encore mystérieuses mais une chose est
certaine les gens de l'antiquité était
en lutte contre le temps essayant
désespérément d'atteindre la vie
éternelle
il est impossible d'affirmer que tous
les efforts de l'antiquité était vain
leur succès et leur échec reste
dissimulés dans l'obscurité voile et de
la mort
derrière les mots mis soigneusement
préservés il y avait un espoir une sorte
de rêve où les gens faisaient
courageusement face à leur propre mort
et refusait la passivité